yesterday was truly a day for the
history books in the United States there
aren't that many days every decade never
mind Century
um like what we saw yesterday the failed
former president Donald Trump was
arrested booked indicted and pleaded not
guilty for 37 felony counts was
instructed not to be in contact with any
other defendants nor Witnesses a
requirement which he immediately broke
last night Trump then flew back to his
Bedminster New Jersey Golf Resort I
think it is where he actually
admitted to some of the crimes that he
is accused of despite claiming total
innocence and claiming that he didn't do
anything and we now move into two
different new phases the pre-trial phase
with this latest Federal indictment as
well as the waiting game for what may be
a second Federal indictment for Trump's
role in the January 6th Trump riots and
a state indictment out of the state of
Georgia for Trump's attempt to
incorrectly fraudulently illegally
overturn the correct results from
Georgia in 2020 in which now President
Joe Biden won the popular vote of
Georgia and subsequently the electoral
votes from Georgia so let's start at the
beginning
the Miami Herald reporting Trump sits
silently in Miami courtroom pleads not
guilty in historic case former president
Donald Trump pleaded not guilty Tuesday
in Miami Federal Court to a 37-count
indictment accusing him of deliberately
keeping at his Palm Beach estate
government documents that contained
highly sensitive defense weapons and
nuclear information and of obstructing
efforts by U.S authorities to reclaim
them in a packed courtroom and remember
there were no cameras in the courtroom
so all we have are these descriptions in
a packed courtroom Trump entered his
plea in a historic case marking the
First Federal prosecution of a former
president and a potential hurdle in his
renewed quest for the presidency in the
2024 election Trump's lawyer Todd
Blanche representing Trump alongside
Chris Keys said quote we most certainly
enter a plea of not guilty Trump was
arraigned a day before his 77th birthday
that will be relevant later as well
appearing before Magistrate Judge
Jonathan Goodman Trump said nothing
during the 45-minute proceeding
prosecutor David harbach told the judge
his team would prepare a list of
witnesses with whom Trump cannot
communicate about the case before the
trial Trump was released on his own
recognizance with no monetary Bond and
no travel restrictions so I think it's
important to mention one of the reasons
that this indictment generally is
important
is that we want a justice system that
doesn't have exceptions where no one is
above the law and despite what you're
hearing from the magats magadonians uh
megapotamians whatever you want to call
them despite what you're hearing from
them that this is evidence of a
two-tiered justice system in a bad way
in fact we know we have a two-tier
justice system Trump being indicted is
maybe a slight half step in the
direction of no one is above the law
however there still are favoritisms that
are being given to Trump including the
fact that he was released on his own
recognizance with no monetary Bond as
well as no travel restrictions many
other defendants not former presidents
of the United States by the way
individuals without private jets with
which they could fly anywhere at any
time would have been given a monetary
Bond and may have had travel
restrictions put in place so just
something to keep in mind the associated
press also reporting and they have an
interesting drawing of what the scene in
the courtroom looked like Trump
reportedly looking glum and having his
arms crossed at many moments during this
writes Trump approached his arraignment
with characteristic bravado posting
social media broadsides against the
prosecution from inside his motorcade on
route to the courthouse and insisting
that he has done nothing wrong and was
being persecuted for political purposes
we are going to discuss that but the
article writes inside the courtroom he
sat silently scowling an arms crossed as
a lawyer entered a not guilty plea on
his behalf in a brief arraignment that
ended without him having to surrender
his passport etc etc
always in campaign mode he swiftly
pivoted from a solemn courtroom to a
festive restaurant stopping on his way
out of Miami at Versailles an iconic
Cuban spot where listen we'll talk about
this later but they sang Happy Birthday
to Trump trump turning 77 today and also
prayed over Trump which was really quite
a scene what we are going to look at
today and much of today's program will
be related to The Fallout from this
arrest admittedly and we will talk about
other issues as well and then tomorrow
we will move on part of today's program
is going to look at number one
why is Trump defending himself on the
basis of a different set of restrictions
the presidential records act rather than
the criminal code then that under which
he has been charged we are going to
discuss that why is Trump admitting to
having done many of the things that he
is accused of doing in the indictment
well it's because he thinks that that's
actually a defense of sorts and maybe
most importantly at this point in time
politically for the United States
is this
the get out of jail free card that some
Republicans have been waiting for to say
this is too much we can no longer
support this man for many republican
elected officials this is that moment
for others like Marjorie Taylor Greene
Lauren bobert
um and other people it is not and they
are steadfast steadfast in their support
and lastly what about your average Trump
supporter well Luke Beasley was on the
ground for us in Miami yesterday
interviewing a number of the several
hundred maybe most a thousand people who
came out to support Trump in Miami so we
are going to get to all of that but
let's start with Trump's own speech
after the arrest think of your most
personal emails if you're using a free
email provider you should know that
they're scanning every email you send
and receive even after you delete it
they're usually using the data to build
a picture of your life to show you ads
which many find creepy our sponsor start
mail never scans or tracks your emails
privacy is what comes first and unlike
other email Services when you delete an
email in start mail it is gone forever
it also protects your data by blocking
tracking pixel tools and emails which
companies and hackers can use to track
you you can create unlimited email
aliases to protect your identity and cut
down on spam you can encrypt every email
you send even if the recipient isn't
using encryption start mail gives you 20
gigs of storage that's more than you get
on Gmail and it only takes a few clicks
to migrate all of your emails and
contacts over to start mail go to
startmail.com Pacman to get 50 off your
first year that's only about two bucks a
month the link is down below